a kingdom united in grief
solemn and dignified a fitting tribute
to a man who served his country
so selflessly here at buckingham palace
the stream of well wishes continued
throughout the day oh so so sad
really really upsetting um been crying
on and off all day
yeah just such such sad news a divisive
amusing difficult
entertaining impressive
man i would say because it happened
during the pandemic
is almost hit a little bit harder
because i think everyone
has been at their low point throughout
the pandemic and
i think everyone's looking for that
glimmer of hope
not far from the palace just a few miles
across the capital
the bells of saint paul's chimed their
special tributes
prince philip left his home in london at
the start of the pandemic
nobody knew then it would be for the
last time
he drew his last breath here in windsor
the castle his buttress against the
pandemic
it's so sad i don't know how the queen
is going to cope
because he's been there for her
throughout
you've got somebody in the background
that's been supremely supportive to the
queen
and i think that's the thing that
matters he looked very frail when we saw
him last time coming out of the hospital
but we all wish that he lived to see his
100th birthday
prince philip might not have been the
most popular royal but his death has
been marked
with an outpouring of spontaneous grief
a recognition of his devotion to his
queen
and country and this was witnessed
across every part of the country
including here
in wales i heard it on the radio and i
was just like oh my gosh i messaged like
my whole family
um this morning and um everybody was
just shocked
i was really sad i really like the guys
got such a lot of character
i hadn't really followed him that much
until the storm on the crown
he contributed so much to that and i
love his energy so yeah i'm really sad
to hear that i just saw like an
instagram post it was just like prince
philip have died nothing else
yeah and like i was quite i wasn't we
were saying we weren't surprised because
he was quite old but obviously it's
always
sad and like for the queen because
they're married for so long
but take him back really you know i know
he's been ill for some time
but yeah she's gonna find the queen's
gonna find it very hard
in northern ireland not everyone will
mourn a royal death
but even many of those who don't will
acknowledge the loss felt by their
neighbors
who do he was an absolute gentleman
i'm devastated to be honest with you
very sad yeah he's great man great man
yeah no doubt
and uh sad you know a good man a very
good man
he must be good when he was married 70
years
you know he was the duke of edinburgh
prince philip's love affair with
scotland spanned eight
decades beginning as a child at school
and staying with him
until the end on his death the scots
returned
that love quite often uh raises a laugh
for
maybe about the wrong reasons but a good
yeah a good ambassador let's see i just
feeling of shock and and disbelief i was
walking in the
in hollywood earlier when they were
lowering the flag and it was the real
a moment to take a moment and reflect on
a life of service and duty
it's sad i mean they gave us 70 years
good service so
yeah it's devastating the prince enjoyed
a full life but horses were one of his
greatest loves
at aintree silence fell to mark the
passing
of one of racing's greatest supporters
what a great man he's been for the
country and i think we all owe him
enormous debt for you know how
he's stood by her majesty herself
and and i know how much she appreciated
all that he did but
he's going to be sorely missed by an
enormous amount of people
buckingham palace has asked for people
not to gather
at royal residences and to respect
coveted restrictions
but that may prove difficult this is
the challenge facing the authorities now
we've never been
in a position like this before a royal
death in the middle
of a global pandemic it's absolutely
natural
for people to want to come here to pay
their respects
prince philip himself did not want to
fuss
and the palace is concerned about mass
gatherings
but there is a real need for so many to
honor a life spent
in selfless service to his country
ashish joshi sky news buckingham palace